amanda bynes enjoy some retail therapy  after reemerging into the spotlight I'm  doing great thank you  really great  [Music]  the 31 year old actress was spotted out  and about with her gal pal on Rodeo  Drive in Beverly Hills on Thursday  Amanda looked fresh-faced and summer  chic for the shopping trip she opted for  a see-through blouse pleated maxi skirt  and trendy oversized Sony's the outing  marks the former all that stars first  public sighting since giving her first  sit-down interview following a four-year  hiatus i jus miss acting and actually  something surprising to tell you I'm  going to start acting again I am at  peace with myself and below it's all  good I want to do TV maybe a few guest  spots on some shows but I'm a fan of and  maybe another TV show where I'm the star  of it  you